If you take your Bibles and turn with me to Ephesians chapter three, please,
Ephesians chapter three, we've been walking through the book of Ephesians
together verse by verse.
And, uh, and now we've come to this chapter.
Um, just as you're turning there this past week, I started thinking about
old commercials.
Now I was, I was a nineties kid and, uh, so that was really the
heyday of catchy commercials and I'll fight anybody over that.
Um, you know, I didn't like coffee, but I knew that the best time of waking up
was Folgers in your cup.
Uh, I was a fan, however, of pizza and I just knew that bagel bites was
going to revolutionize the pizza industry because you could have pizza
in the morning, pizza in the evening, pizza at separate time when pizza's
on a bagel.
You remember the last bit?
You can eat pizza.
That's it.
Anytime.
Um, but one, uh, stuck out to me that this is what got me thinking
about it was, uh, I remember the commercials where somebody would turn
up on your doorstep with, with some balloons and a giant check, right?
The publisher's clearinghouse, uh, commercials.
Uh, and I remember seeing that and they would kind of record the raw
reactions of people who were receiving the prize money.
They were going to be a, you know, a millionaire now.
And I don't know what I would have done with that million dollars as a
kid, but I was, I was ready for the balloons to turn up at the door
and the, you know, the check to be given, uh, to me.
Uh, but as I was thinking about that, I thought, well, if you, if
you're not given the check, I guess the second best person to be
there is the person who's actually delivering the check.
I mean, imagine that being your job, like your job every day is to
go and tell people you have now won a million dollars.
Like that's your job that you're continually, uh, doing.
It would have been pretty thrilling.
Now what got me thinking about that was what Paul says about
himself in our passage this morning.
He had a greater job than letting people know about temporary riches.
He had been given the role of preaching the unsearchable riches
of Christ.
He let people know about Jesus and all that they had been given
in him.
So let's read that together.
Ephesians chapter three verses one to 13.
It says, for this reason, I, Paul, a prisoner of Christ Jesus
on behalf of you Gentiles, assuming that you have heard of
the stewardship of God's grace that was given to me for you,
how the mystery was made known to me by revelation.
As I have written briefly, when you read this or when you read
this rather, you can perceive my insight into the mystery of
Christ, which was not made known to the sons of men in other
generations as it has now been revealed to his holy apostles
and prophets by the spirit.
This mystery is that the Gentiles are fellow heirs,
members of the same body and partakers of the promise
in Christ Jesus through the gospel.
Of this gospel, I was made a minister according to the gift
of God's grace, which was given me by the working of his power.
To me, though I am the very least of all the saints, this
grace was given to preach to the Gentiles, the unsearchable
riches of Christ and to bring to light for everyone.
What is the plan of the mystery hidden for ages in God who
created all things so that through the church, the manifold
wisdom of God might now be made known to the rulers and
authorities in the heavenly places.
This was according to the eternal purpose that he has
realized in Christ Jesus, our Lord in whom we have boldness
and access with confidence through our faith in him.
So I ask you not to lose heart over what I am suffering
for you, which is your glory.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
By your spirit, I pray that you would open our eyes to behold
wondrous things in your word.
Help us to see the treasure that it really is.
Show us more of Jesus.
We pray.
We pray this in his name.
Amen.
Over the past couple of weeks, as we've walked through
Ephesians two together, we've seen our collective identity
as the church, if you will.
So when Luke preached last week, he helpfully pointed out
that God has given us a new identity as his people.
We are citizens of God's kingdom, members of his family.
We are the temple in which he dwells.
This is our identity together as the church.
So Paul, having spoken of our collective identity as the
church, now shifts slightly and talks about who he is personally.
He talks about his calling and how it relates to the church.
And in the process of talking about himself, he also tells us
more about who we are and more importantly about who Jesus is.
So for the next few moments, I just want to draw out three
things from the passage that he tells us here.
And they all start with M, not because I'm clever, but because
that is what is here in the passage, these three M words.
All right, so we're going to see, I'll go ahead and give
them to you.
We're going to see the mystery of the gospel.
And then we're going to see the ministry of the gospel.
And then we're going to see the manifold wisdom of God.
This is how it unfolds before us here.
So we see, first of all, the mystery of the gospel.
Paul repeatedly refers to the message he is proclaiming as a
mystery.
You see this in verse three, verse four, verse nine.
Everybody loves a good mystery.
I don't know what comes to mind when you think of that.
Maybe playing like Clue or reading an Agatha Christie
novel.
Once again, being a kid of the 90s, I think of the sixth
sense.
And if you've not seen it, I'm not necessarily recommending that
you go and see that.
It was a pretty, I remember being scared out of my wits sitting
in the theater watching it.
And but when it got to the very end, there was such a huge
twist at the end that I just had to see it again because
what happened at the end, what was revealed at the end,
then colored the rest of the movie.
There were things that had been there all along that
I had not seen and I'm not going to let you know what
that is in case you did want to see it.
I don't want to ruin it for you.
But there's a mystery Paul's talking about here and the word
he uses for mystery.
Yes, is something that is hidden, but it's not something
that remains hidden.
When he talks about the mystery, he's not saying that his
message is vague or unknowable.
What he is talking about is that it is an open secret,
something that was once hidden has now been revealed.
So yes, there's a mystery, but we've already got to the
end of the plot.
We've seen the end of the movie and now we can see this
mystery right the way through this open secret.
So what is the mystery?
Well, we don't have to do any guesswork as Paul tells us
plainly in verse 6.
So let's read that again together.
This mystery is that the Gentiles are fellow heirs,
members of the same body and partakers of the promise
in Christ Jesus through the gospel.
All right.
So the mystery that is revealed is the fact that through
Christ, there was now one people of God that's made up
of Jew and Gentile alike.
And we saw that over the past two weeks in chapter two,
it's summarized really in verse 15 of chapter two where
he says that God has created one new man in place of
the two in the church.
Right.
So all the blessings that have been promised to God's
people belong to all of us who are in Christ,
regardless of our ethnicity.
Right.
So there's one body, one people of God.
So that's what the mystery is right.
So he's returning back to that thought here.
And what he tells us here is this mystery was once hidden.
Okay.
So it's revealed now, but it was once hidden verse nine
for ages in God.
Nevertheless, it was there all along.
It was part of God's eternal purpose.
We see there in verse 11.
So you can catch glimpses of this truth that there
will one day be this, this body called the church was
Jew and Gentile alike in this one people.
But you see these it's not as plain as it is now.
So let's just go back in the Old Testament.
So take Genesis chapter 12.
For example, when God called Abram, he said it through him
and through his offspring, all the families of the earth
would be blessed.
So it's clear from the beginning God has a plan not just
for this one people, but for all peoples for all nations.
You go to a place like Isaiah two and it talks about
the nations one day coming to God and knowing his ways
and walking in them.
So what wasn't clear though, just clear God has a plan
for all nations, but what wasn't clear is that they were
going to be incorporated into one body and that they were
going to inherit the same blessings together in Christ.
So it isn't just that I mean think of the blessings
that we now have in him.
It isn't just that there's a people of God out there
and we get some of the allowance kind of on the outside of that.
Now we're brought in fully.
Like we're given cards to the same account to draw from.
We are fellow heirs we're told here.
We are members of the same body, partakers of the promise.
So if your faith is in Christ, you belong to the family
of God.
You completely belong.
And this wasn't a change of plan in the mind of God.
God's plan was being slowly and gradually unfolded,
but all of it was baked in right from the beginning.
Right?
There's this progressive revelation that takes place.
I mean you can think of it, I don't know, like an eight week scan of a baby.
I remember when we found out we're going to be having a baby
and the eight weeks came and we had the scan.
I remember seeing the picture and it was like,
wow, yep, there's a peanut.
I don't know exactly what I'm looking at here.
And I was slightly wondering whether or not they just keep a few of them
in the drawer to just hand to people.
I wouldn't have known if it was my child or not.
But then several weeks later we had another scan.
And then sure enough you could see that that peanut had developed into
what was starting to look like a baby.
And of course then the baby was born
and now that peanut is taller than his mother.
So there's different stages.
But right from the beginning, even when you couldn't see where things were heading,
it was all there.
So developmentally things come along.
And this is what happens with God's plan of redemption.
All of it was there from the beginning in the heart of God
and it is revealed over time.
And what Paul is writing here is another installment
in that redemption plan being revealed.
So it's being made known through the apostles and prophets.
We're told here, you go back to chapter two in verse 20.
It's repeated now in chapter three in verse five.
So God's revealed this one new man.
This one people of God to his apostles and prophets.
So his job was then to shine a light on that truth
that was once hidden in the dark.
Okay, so this was given to the apostles to reveal.
All right, so this is a few things about that really quick.
One is that this was a unique work that was given to the apostles and prophets.
We're told in chapter two in verse 20 that the role of apostles and prophets
was foundational in the life of the church.
So foundations are not continually laid.
They are laid and then built upon.
So we have the truth revealed here.
It's recorded for us in the scriptures.
All right, so there's this unique work that was given to the apostles.
And we have it for us in the New Testament.
Another thing is that the church is then built on the word of God
and that word centers on Jesus.
So the truth that has been revealed in scripture is now realized in the church.
Right, so as people come to faith in Christ and they are brought into this body
and it's through the preaching of the word that people are then brought into the family of God
and it's through the word that we are then built up together as the people of God.
And this is why the reading and the preaching of the word
last remained central in our life as a church, as we worship together at Trinity Fellowship.
Final thing there, another thing is that the word that is given to us isn't just true.
It is precious.
Right, so Paul, this word was given to Paul and the other apostles and prophets,
we now receive it through the word we're being built up by it.
And as we see it, we see that it's not just true, it is precious.
So opening up the word isn't like just opening up an encyclopedia, it's opening up a treasure chest.
You see that at the end of verse 8?
It's here that we see all the treasures that are ours in Jesus.
Right, so we had our opening scripture, Psalm 19.
There we see God's glory as being revealed in creation.
You think about the most beautiful, wonderful thing that you can imagine in the whole universe.
Well, that is pointing to something that is even greater and that is the glory of God.
And then the Psalm goes on to talk about God's glory being revealed in His Word.
It is more to be desired than gold.
It is sweeter than honey, right?
So God is revealing His glory in His Word.
And so now we have the word pointing to who Jesus is to us
and what He has done in bringing us together into His people.
So if it was the case before the God's Word was precious,
how much more is it now that we have come to know Jesus,
the one that the Word has been pointing to all along?
Alright, so that's the mystery of the gospel.
We can be part of the body of Christ together and receive all the blessings that come with that.
Secondly, let's also see that Paul talks about the ministry of the gospel.
So look at with me at verse 7.
He says, of this gospel, of this good news,
I was made a minister according to the gift of God's grace.
Let's pause there.
So Paul was made a minister.
So many of you know I had the privilege of serving in England for a number of years
and over in the UK pastors are often referred to as ministers.
And so one of my boys was at school one day.
It was a Gideon I believe.
And his teacher sat him down.
He was really little.
And I think he was four or five years old.
And they said, so your daddy's a minister.
And he said, no, a prime minister.
So I don't know if he thought, you know, I was kind of running the country in my spare time while he was at school.
I don't know, it gave me a big head for a day or two.
But when Paul refers to himself as a minister here, he's not kind of talking himself up.
It's not that he's got a big head.
He isn't kind of lauding his importance.
It's an expression of humility.
Right. The word literally means servant.
He's saying, I'm a servant of the gospel.
In fact, he puts himself even lower in verse eight when he refers to himself as the very least of all the saints.
In fact, when you look at the original language here, you almost kind of like makes up a word, right?
There's the word least and he adds another like thing to the end of it.
So like, I'm not just the least. I'm the leaster.
I'm not the least important or the lowest. I'm the lowest or lowest s s.
He's like, however low you can imagine that, that's me.
Why is he saying that?
Well, it's not a kind of false humility here.
It's the fact that he is deeply aware of what God has saved him from.
If you go back and read the book of Acts, you see that he was once a persecutor of the church that he is now serving.
And so God's grace has brought him that far from death to life, from darkness to light.
You might wonder, then, well, how did this persecutor become a preacher?
How is he the one through which God is giving this gospel out, making this mystery known?
And what does this ministry tell us about ourselves?
A couple of things. One is ministry is the work of God.
We see that in Paul. That's how he became a minister.
Not only God could have made Saul of Tarsus a minister of the gospel, this Paul that we read about here.
And that's exactly how he describes it.
First of all, notice Paul says, I was made a minister.
That's passive language being used there.
This isn't something that he did. It was something that was done to him.
It was something that he had received from outside of himself.
God did it. So how did God do it?
We can talk about God's grace.
Verse 7, he was made a minister according to God's grace.
So apostleship wasn't kind of at the top of the vocational ladder he was climbing.
It wasn't a position that he had earned or had worked for, anything like that.
It was a gift freely given by God.
God was pleased to pour out his grace upon him and give him this responsibility to make that grace known to others.
So he's giving out of the grace that he has received from God.
He doesn't just speak about God's grace making him a minister.
He speaks about God's power making him a minister as well.
The grace was given to him, he says, by the working of God's power.
You may remember earlier in Ephesians, God's power was spoken of in relation to Jesus' resurrection.
He was raised by God's power.
And that same power was spoken of in terms of our own conversion.
So when we come to faith in Christ, it's because we too are raised by God's power.
God gives us new life in Christ, this power.
So it was God's power that overcame the resistance of Saul when he became a minister of the gospel.
It was God's power that brought him to himself and made him new in Christ.
And it was God's power that was enabling him to carry out his calling now as a minister.
And he also speaks not only of God's grace and power, but also God's purpose.
So look at me at verse 2.
At the beginning he talks about his ministry as being a stewardship of God's grace.
That's the same word used in Ephesians chapter 1 and verse 10 to refer to God's plan, God's stewardship,
to unite all things in Jesus.
Now he's talking about Paul's talking about his role to carry out God's plans.
So the idea is like God's made the plans.
He's drawn up the blueprint and now Paul is getting to work fulfilling those plans according to God's will.
So God's plan is to glorify himself by creating this global family called the church.
And Paul's role here is to preach the gospel so that it is brought about.
So it's according to the work of God, this work that God is doing through the gospel.
That's how Paul was made a minister.
But also I want us to see that it was for the good of others, for the good of others.
Back when I was in Bible college years ago, I remember the pastor of the church that had kind of started this college
preached from Ephesians chapter 3 and verse 2 to us students.
And instead of preaching as normal that day, he just took the last four words of verse 2 as his sermon.
It was to me, for you.
And he kind of took the chance to give his testimony.
And right the way he would start off and talk about how God had saved him.
But that was given to me for you.
And he started talking about the different ways God had worked in his life.
Now he's an older man.
He could just see that yes the Lord had been gracious to him but it wasn't just for himself.
It was for others.
He was learning that lesson.
He wanted to drive that home to us and really stuck out.
So Paul says what God had given was to him, yes, but it wasn't merely for him.
It was for others.
So Paul doesn't show us his LinkedIn profile here or some kind of resume.
Like look at all my accolades.
His ministry isn't for himself.
It isn't self promotion.
It's for the good that God was going to bring about in the lives of others through him.
And it was so good seeing that happen.
And he was even willing to, like if it meant Paul suffering, what God is doing through him,
it's so glorious he's even willing to suffer to see that happen.
So this is written from prison, you see in verse one.
Paul is in prison for preaching the gospel.
At the end of our section here in verse 13, Paul tells them he doesn't want them to be discouraged by his suffering.
Because he's confident that God is accomplishing his good purposes through them in their lives.
So what does that have to do with us then?
This ministry of the gospel.
Well one is what Paul went through in his preaching of the gospel has led to our good this morning.
We are recipients of what Paul writes even here.
We're recipients of this message.
And so first, you know, we're called to respond to that gospel.
But I want us to see what we can learn from his example.
So here's how this applies to us.
One is, you know, let's say we're recipients of that message.
So the gospel that saved Paul, the grace that changed Paul's life, the power that raised him from the dead and gave him new life in Jesus can change anyone's life.
It can change your life.
The Lord can save you and he can use you for his glory.
Another thing I want us to see is that we are all called to gospel ministry.
If you read chapter four you'll see this.
In chapter four verse seven we see that the same grace that had been given to Paul, gifting him, had been given to every single follower of Jesus.
And Paul's role, the role of other church leaders like him was to equip God's people for the work of the ministry.
Right? Because they are called to gospel ministry as well.
And it lays that out.
It shows how we're all called to serve one another in love that we might grow together in the likeness of Jesus.
So we're all in gospel ministry.
And gospel ministry is a gift.
When we think about ministry and what we're doing here in the church, like this is not about self-actualization.
It's about serving others out of the grace of God that has been given to us.
It's about making Christ known for God's glory and for the good of those around me.
Another thing is that kind of gospel ministry is difficult work, but it is worth it.
It is so worth it.
It involves suffering.
Yes, you may even have to sit out in the cold.
But it is worth it.
It does all of us good to step back though and remember what an amazing privilege we have been given.
That God would call people like us to himself and would use us for his good purposes in the lives of others and in the world at large.
So I could just say that as we step into this week of thanksgiving, let's just pause and remember how much we have to be grateful to God for.
God has been so gracious to us.
He's given us his son.
He's made us his own.
And he's given us one another in the church.
He's given us all of these promises we sang about and we've read about here.
By the way, could I just say I'm so grateful for every one of you as well.
The way you've been serving the Lord and serving one another here as this new church is getting started.
It's been so evident that this work of the ministry is something that we are all involved in.
I can't wait to see what the Lord accomplishes in the days ahead.
However cold it gets to return to that thing.
Let's remember to warm our hearts by this fire.
God is gracious.
God is powerful.
God is accomplishing his purposes.
This is about his glory and the good of others.
So what is God doing here?
Let's come to this final M.
It's about the manifold wisdom of God.
We read this in chapter three in verse 10.
So Paul is carrying out this ministry, proclaiming the mystery rather.
So that through the church, the manifold wisdom of God might now be made known.
That's why we're here to display the manifold wisdom of God.
That's why the church exists.
If you know Christ, this is what you are part of.
So what does that mean?
This might be a surprising way if I were to ask you this morning,
what's the purpose of the church to display the manifold wisdom of God?
Would that be the first thing you could say?
Not necessarily.
So what does this mean here?
Well manifold isn't even a word that we use every day here.
So it essentially means multicolored.
There was a Greek translation of the Old Testament that was being used at the time
and that was the same exact word that was used to talk about Joseph's coat of many colors in Genesis 37.
Right?
So you've got this one coat, but you've got all of these different colors built into this one coat.
This is God's wisdom.
God's wisdom is not monochrome.
It's multicolored and multivariate.
So there's nothing unique about similar people getting together to do things that they all happen to enjoy.
Like pickleball can bring people together.
We can think of any number of common things that bring like-minded people together.
But what God does in the church is unique.
He takes different people from all different backgrounds
and brings them together into one family, into this one body.
And he does so in a way that has both variety present and unity together at the same time
in this kind of coat of many colors.
His wisdom is manifold.
It's multicolored as he brings the churches together from people from all nations.
Well who is this manifold wisdom being displayed to?
So if God's manifold wisdom and glory is being displayed, who's looking on?
What says at the end of verse 10?
It's being displayed to the rulers and authorities in the heavenly places.
So if God's redemption plan is like a drama, you can think of maybe him as like the writer and director.
Maybe Christ as the lead role, but we also have a part to play in this as well.
So who was the audience?
It's the angels.
The angels.
It's interesting we don't often think of it in that way.
At least I don't.
John Stott said it this way.
He said through the old creation God reveals his glory to humans.
Through the new creation God reveals his wisdom to the angels.
So God's revealing his wisdom to the angels.
Well in chapter one we saw that Jesus reigns above all powers in heaven and on earth.
So this is a theme we've come to already.
It could be that Paul's saying that the angels in heaven now have further reason to praise him when they see his wise plan unfolding in the world.
He could also be talking about the power of evil seeing what he's done.
So in chapter two we saw that the powers of evil are at work and those who do not know Christ.
Paul's going to return to that theme of the powers of evil, spiritual evil in chapter six.
So it could be that his greater power is now seen when he frees people, rescues people, saves people from the power of evil when he saves us from sin and death.
But either way God is displaying his glorious manifold wisdom to spiritual powers.
He's doing that through the church.
So where is God's glory seen?
It's through us as the church.
Let's look at it from a couple of perspectives then when we talk about God's glory being displayed in the church.
One is a global perspective.
So go 10,000 feet up and then climb a bit higher.
Maybe imagine one of those pictures that shows cities at night time on earth.
We see all the lights kind of across a country.
You see that from that view we are all part of one glorious global church.
Having served in global mission work in the past I've been able to see some of this beautiful diversity up close.
I can think of the church today even.
Julie and I went to go gather with the church in a cornfield in Burkina Faso made up of first generation Muslim background believers.
I think God's glory is coming up from there as they worship the Lord together.
And that same church was also present in a crowded Soviet block apartment in Belarus.
Gathering together, cramming in that apartment complex with those believers there as they part of this same church are praising God together there.
And here we are this morning at Cornerstone Ranch under this pavilion as part of that one glorious global family.
Now anywhere you look the church will have its kind of strengths and weaknesses and unique things that the Lord is accomplishing there that they are bringing that the kind of glory that he's bringing through them.
But all of us are part of this one global body called the church.
So it is good to remember that global perspective of what the Lord is doing.
He's building his church all over the world.
So let's pray for his work around the world.
Let's send out missionaries.
Let's support them.
Let's remember that he isn't a local God.
He's a God who has a global mission in a global church that he's bringing about.
So that's how his multicolored wisdom is being displayed.
But it also let's come back down to this local church here.
God's manifold wisdom can also be seen when you get right up close in a local body of believers because in every church,
no matter how small it is, is made up of people from different backgrounds,
people with different personalities, people with different perspectives.
And we're all brought into the same church.
And as we walk through the last half of the book of Ephesians,
we're going to see that God's glory is displayed through our interpersonal relationships within the church and within our families as well.
So we have to ask the question, is the love of Christ seen in the way I view and treat other people in my life,
the people that the Lord has placed into my life?
Can God's glory be heard in my words?
Now that kind of variety that we have here in this room or even within our own families,
we'll have our differences with each other for sure.
And the thing about being drawn close to one another is we start to see one another's faults
and even open up the possibility of being hurt by one another too.
It's kind of like hugging a cactus to get close to one another in the life of a church.
And that could drive us apart.
But God, by His grace, wants to draw us in.
And by His wisdom, He is well able to knit us together for His glory as one body.
So God's gracious work looks like care for one another.
And also looks like confession when we get it wrong too.
That's why the gospel is wonderful.
Because we can be honest about our sin and rejoice in our Savior.
It's not easy, but God is gracious and powerful and He has made us one in Christ.
And it's in looking to Him that we find all that we need to keep moving towards one another in love.